hi there and welcome to the channel
so it's an exciting day here down in my
uh growing room because it is time to
start planting tomatoes
indoors getting them ready for the
outdoor garden so i think starting
tomatoes indoors is one of my favorite
indoor starts
i find that they are
one of the easiest things to to get
growing indoors
so this year i am going to do things a
little differently
first of all i'm going to try a
different method of
starting these tomatoes and this is
something that i seen done on a channel
called next level gardening so brian is
the
host of that channel he is down in
southern california which is a
a very different growing zone than here
on saskatchewan prairies
i'm sure his zone must be around eight
or nine
of course here in saskatchewan we are in
zone three which is a very cold growing
zone
but a lot of the the methods that brian
shows on his channel
you know work in in various growing
zones
and i was really interested about this
technique that he showed on
how to start tomatoes
and create a very strong tomato with
very strong roots
that hopefully will give you a better
harvest at the end of the day
so that's one thing different that i'm
going to be doing this year
another thing that i'm going to try
doing this year is starting less
tomatoes
i always find that you know you if i
start them in smaller cells i'll have
like six of one kind six of another kind
six of another kind
just because you're not sure which ones
will germinate and then you have really
good germination
and they grow well and you just you know
don't end up getting rid of any and you
plant them all up into bigger containers
and you know six to eight weeks later
your whole countertop in the garage is
covered with tomatoes plus all the other
vegetables and flowers that i like to
start indoors
so i've told myself this year that i'm
going to limit
the amount of each variety that i'm
going to start
but i do have seven different varieties
that i want to try this year
so i'm going to be just starting
two seeds of each variety
in these red solo cups so that means
i only have seven
starts going here
and my hope is that these tomato plants
can stay in these red solo cups right
from the time they sprout until they are
ready to go out in the garden
so
looking at it this way
if all goes well and i get seven
plants going this is the only space that
they're going to take up
so getting back to this technique that
brian uh talks about on his channel it
is all about starting your tomato
in a
solo cup like this or a container uh
similar to this size it could be like a
four inch uh container
and
what he does is he only fills the
container up about halfway
plants the seeds
and lets the tomato germinate and grow
and as it grows
just to keep adding
soil around
the stem of the tomato
and the reason for that is because
tomatoes
as long as you bury their stem
all those little tiny hairs that i will
show you up close here in a minute will
turn into roots
so the theory behind this is as the
tomato grows we keep covering the stem
it shoots out more roots so by the time
this is ready to go into the ground you
have a very solid root ball
on a very strong plant
and hopefully we'll have a very good
harvest at the end of the season so here
on the saskatchewan prairies we have a
very short outdoor growing season
that
is usually approximately 110 days from
in between the two frost dates
so tomatoes are one of those things that
you have to start indoors there's just
no way you would ever be able to start
them outdoors
and i usually do them about
six to eight weeks prior to the last
frost date
here our last frost date is about the
third week of may
and for tomatoes i
personally usually wait a little bit
longer than that
last frost date and go with pretty much
the first week of june
i've had a lot of
experience with late frosts
coming at the end of may early june so i
consider myself just a small scale
gardener i don't grow a huge amount of
any type of vegetable for the purpose of
canning or
saving it for the winter being that i
work full time and have other hobbies
that i enjoy doing i try not to
grow too much of anything i want to be
able to just enjoy it throughout the
summer and into the fall
and any tomatoes that i do end up with
at the end of the season that doesn't
look like we're going to be able to eat
fresh you know i will do some freezing
but
for the most part i just like to grow
different varieties i like the cherry
type tomatoes i like the beef steaks and
i've been
very lucky to get a whole bunch of
different kinds of tomato seeds through
a seed exchange here in canada and i'm
pretty excited to try all of these and
see how they turn out
and because we do have a short growing
season here it's always good to try and
find tomatoes that have a shorter
growing period such as
this one here this is called the
roadster tomato but i received this from
dean scott birchwood builders is his
youtube channel he's in alberta
he sent these to me
they are a large meaty flavorful
determinate tomato so when i looked them
up online they're kind of a bigger one
it's a nice slicing tomato be great for
sandwiches
and these have a 65 days to maturity so
what that means is when these get
transplanted into the ground
you should have
tomatoes 65 days later so if i get these
into the ground
early june that means that i should have
some tomatoes before the
end of july
hickory crop farms is another youtube
channel that i do a lot of seed
exchanging with they are located in
ontario and they have sent me three
different kinds of
tomato seeds that i am excited to try
this one's called the palestinian tomato
it has a
longer maturity date so it says
85 to 100 days so that that is really
pushing it for saskatchewan
so it will be interesting to see if i
can get some of these
these are also a beef steak tomato but
they are an indeterminate variety which
means that they will keep growing and
producing all summer long until until
they die or
usually till the frost comes
the other one that they gave me was a
white tomasol tomato which again was a
very interesting looking tomato to me
it is also a
indeterminate variety it has a long
maturity date as well of 80 days
so we will see how those go
i also got a bush beefsteak determinant
from
plowman's backyard
youtube channel check it out
so this is a determinate short season
type tomato so i like that it's only 62
days to maturity
so the determinate tomatoes will only
grow so high usually about three or four
feet tall
they will bloom produce their fruit and
then they're done
this is one i'm very excited about
because i love sun gold cherry tomatoes
and i got these also from
dean at birchwood builders he sent me
some of those after i was asking for
them on a seed exchange video they have
a short growing season of 60 to 65 days
and he wrote on here that they are
yellow
sweet juicy and you can't eat just one
so looking forward to those
this is from heritage harvest seeds they
are located in manitoba
and this is called a pink ping pong
tomato so it is an indeterminate cherry
tomato
it's got a 75 day to maturity
period so
should see something from these you know
early august
this one doesn't really
qualify as a tomato but i'm going to be
planting it with my tomatoes anyway
another one from hickory crop farms it's
aunt molly's ground cherries these kind
of interests me i've seen a lot of
videos of people growing them i've seen
a lot of mixed reviews
from people as to whether they like them
or not but just a very interesting
looking plant that i'm going to try
growing
and we will see how they go so these are
70 days to maturity from transplant
so we will add this to my variety here
today
so i think i have a good variety i have
a few determinant type i have a few that
will be the larger beefsteak kind of
tomato
and i also have a couple of the cherry
varieties so i'm very excited to get
them planted here and show you
my method that i'm going to be following
so i think because i'm only going to be
starting one of each of these containers
i'm going to be
putting three seeds into each just to
ensure that i have
successful germination
i'm trying to just plant them close to
the center here because i know i'm only
going to be keeping one in here
something that brian also on his video
that i was watching used instead of
putting some more seed starting mix on
the top of the soil he used vermiculite
which i have been doing for
my other indoor starts the vericulite is
supposed to help prevent
damping off and
fungus gnats getting into your soil here
so with my seed starting mix here i also
add
boiling water to it to moisten the soil
and to kind of give it a bit of extra
sterilization to prevent
fungus gnats in case there happens to be
some eggs in the soil
it's just a little extra measure i like
to use just to help prevent the fungus
gnats getting into your
dirt in your house which is a can be a
real pain
so this is how it's going to look after
the
initial planting so i have put three
seeds in there put a light layer of
vermiculite on the top
with these red solo cups i've just taken
scissors and made a few little slits at
the bottom so that it has drainage and
somewhere for the roots to go because
i'm pretty sure by the time these are
ready to go outdoors they're going to
have roots
shooting out the bottom
so here's what the beefsteak tomato
looks like about i think it's been
almost a month since i planted these so
i have the cup filled halfway
planted them up
and now to take advantage of
this special
thing that tomatoes have
if you can see all those tiny little
fibers that are on the stem of a tomato
those
will turn into roots if you cover them
with soil
so this is the
technique that we are going to use today
i'm going to remove
those first two leaves
and this one as well
and this one here
so it doesn't look like you're left with
much but once we
top it up with soil right up to here
all these tiny little fibers that you
can see are going to turn into roots
and this will keep growing
upwards so then by the time we have this
in the garden this is going to be a
really nice strong
tomato plant
so this is what he looks like once he's
got another layer of soil he's still got
a lot of nice leaves here
growing and
as i said the stem that we just covered
up
will
shoot out a bunch more roots
so i'm just going to put this back under
the grow lights
so one thing that i just got thinking
about with these ground cherries is that
they don't have the same
special
properties that the tomatoes have where
their
stems
will shoot out roots if you bury them at
least not that i
read anywhere
so i'm going to fill this container
up all the way
just put about
four or five seeds
like i said i don't have a lot of
knowledge of ground cherries just a few
uh youtube videos i watched i would love
to hear anybody's comments on their
experiences with these like i said i it
seems like a really mixed reviews on
whether people like them or not
so to start these off i'm going to be
using this heat mat
it's not totally necessary to use one
but if you have one it's a good a good
way to to help kind of jump start the uh
this germination i'm going to put these
cups directly onto the mat for now
and just
keep them moist by spritzing the tops of
them
and i do have
a container all ready to put these into
once they get sprouting and i have them
under the lights that i can bottom water
them
directly into this tray
so i'm not going to have a grow light
going on them right now until they
germinate
if you have some kind of a dome type
thing that you can use
i always just use a plastic bag because
it's easy to maneuver and fit over any
sizes of cups that i
am working on here so i'm just going to
keep the plastic on here
until i start seeing germination
which
according to most of these packages is
within seven to ten days
i have found with tomatoes
that i've growing indoors that they do
germinate a lot quicker than that
sometimes within four days i see
germination
so once i have
a germination happening on all of these
i will
take off the plastic and
turn on the grow light maybe move them
up a little bit closer
so we'll just keep monitoring that so
that's pretty much all there is to
starting tomatoes indoors and i will be
starting a lot more things over the next
few weeks as we get closer to that lost
last frost date so i hope you will keep
watching if you haven't already done so
please hit subscribe
and
leave a comment
i will be doing all sorts of updates on
everything that i've started so far
and i hope that you will just keep
following along with me on my channel
thank you for watching and we'll see you
on the next one